صحيح طاهر فالحمايه الامريكيه للامن
القومي الاسرائيليه لا تخفي الشكوك حول
امكانيه حدوث شرخ في العلاقات بين البلدين
خاصه في ظل عزمنه ياهو اتخاذ خطوات
تعارضها هذه الشكوك رصدتها دراسه لجامعه
تل ابيب التي استعرضت ايضا اهم التهديدات
التي يواجهها نتنياهو في السنه الجايه من
بينها الازمه الداخليه بعض الاصلاحات
القضائيه التي اقترحها والتي خلقت جدلا
واسعا لكن التهديد الاهم بحسب الصحيفه
يبقى خارجيا في ظل تربص التهديد الايراني
باسرائيل الدراسه كشفت ان اسرائيل تخشى
ايران في الفتره الحاليه اكثر من اي وقت
مضى في ظل انشغال الغربي وبخاصه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بالحرب الاوكرانيه الى
جانب التهديدات الاقليميه للصين فتى
الابيب مدعوه بمفردها لمواجهه ايران
وتحديدا برنامج النووي الذي يتقدم بسريه
تامه كما تقول الدراسه اسرائيل مضت بالفعل
في مواجهه التهديد الايراني وذلك بعمليه
متواصله منذ سنوات ليست بالقليله بل حتى
ان الموساد الاسرائيلي كان قد تغلغل في
العمق الايراني ونجح في سرقه ارشيف ايران
النووي والكلام هنا منسوب الى وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي السابق
في كتابه الجديد نافر جيف اندنش ان
المخابرات الامريكيه ساعدت عملاء الموساد
على الفراري من ايران في فبراير من سنه
2018 بعد ان نجحوا في سرقه ارشيف ايران
النووي السري من قلب طهران بومبيه وصف
العمليه ايضا بانها واحده من اهم العمليات
السريه التي تم اجرائها على الاطلاق